The Joe Rogan experience is that you and
Rodney dangerfield.
Did you double as Rodney?
I did double hip a few times,
but movie was this.
Oh God.
A couple of TV shows I had.
It was a picture of you guys up there.
What's that?
Dad?
Can you say?
Uh,
yeah,
he,
uh,
yeah,
we,
I was doing sword fighting then sword
fighting.
Oh yeah,
definitely him.
And uh,
he was quite a character,
quite a character.
He would always leave his pants zipped
and um,
so I had uh,
one of the actors say,
Hey,
his pants,
he'd go up and he says I'm getting air
conditioning.
Don't bother me.
And he just did it as a square of a
joke.
Right.
With like the robes and stuff is like
balls.
And I've talked about this before,
but I worked at Great Woods,
Concert Center in Mansfield,
Massachusetts when I was a kid.
I was a,
amongst the security personnel there.
And so I was backstage and I got to see
Rodney as he was preparing for a show.
He would just have a robot and nothing
else.
He was wearing slippers and he had a
robot.
And he was walking around back there,
this is before I'd ever done standup
comedy,
but I was like,
that guy is the shit.
Like,
look at him.
He's just,
he's literally as comfortable as you can
get.
He's wearing a bathrobe on purpose and
it's because he could,
you know,
he was like,
[inaudible],
I can whatever.
I'm just gonna wear a bathrobe.
It's comfortable.
I like the way I love the way he does it
because he can because he keeps fucking.
Rodney did.
He knew he was Rodney dangerfield.
He never said anything and he played it
straight and apparently a super nice
guy,
like everybody I know that did business
with them or had any interactions with
them,
always came away from it.
Same Rodney.
He's a great guy.
My friend Jeff,
my manager,
Jeff,
he was with one of,
uh,
one of his clients was one of Rodney's
original comics on the Hbo Comedy Series
that he did.
And he said that Rodney was just the
best.
Just the coolest,
nicest guy.
But it happens all the time.
I know.
But what's worse than that are fucking
your sister having sex with your sister.
That's worth,
I think the victim.
There were consistent.
Wants it.
You want it?
I thought about that.
There's one.
I will go to my grave saying I've never
had sex with my sister.
That's a good move.
Yeah.
There's some things you want to keep off
the resume.
That would be.
Well,
you don't even want to do it and then
go,
well that was a mistake.
Never do that again because you can't
really erase it.
Just kind of fucked man.
Because like isn't like learning like
one of the most important parts of life.
Like shouldn't you be allowed to fuck
up?
But you can't.
There's certain fuck ups you can't make.
Like you can't be like,
you know a baby.
I want to marry you.
I want to marry you too.
But I gotta tell you this one thing I
know,
I know this is not going to change
anything because we're meant to be with
each other,
but I fucked my cousin.
Your wife's going to be like,
what?
Why don't you fuck your cousin?
Wait a minute.
Which cousin?
Guy,
how far?
Wait,
wait,
Whoa,
whoa.
I fucked my cousin Mike.
How far was the,
is it a first cousin or is it a uh,
yeah,
it'd to be a first cousin.
Was your second cousin?
That's it's gay sex.
Um,
I think no one's going to be happy with
you,
you know,
if your wife's not happy that you fucked
your cousin.
But this is the,
that was a joke brody.
But if it's straight trash,
my aunt antlers.
If it's straight,
it's straight sex.
I think I'm the second cousin is
actually like legal,
like you can not only fuck them,
you can marry them,
right?
Yeah.
Lewis first cousin.
Can I ask you a question?
Not,
you're not supposed to.
It's been on my mind and I know you
probably don't want to talk about it
because it was brought.
Oh well thanks for bringing it up on the
Internet.
What was brought up in it?
Well,
I'm just being real.
Who's brought up in you?
I think you were uneasy with it.
It was an ice house.
Chronical.
I'm.
Why would you bring it up again?
Because I heard Joe talked about gay
sex.
Like I have to make it clear.
I'm not into that.
Oh,
why do you have to make that clear?
Because I get hassled for it.
Sometimes it goes back to you again.
Brody notice,
well,
going back to him and gay sex.
Apparently you can have sex with your
cousin.
It's legal.
What of your cousins?
A transsexual than a.
it's even more legal.
Depends if you're a.
If you're telling someone who writes for
Salon,
you're in a few girls that have been
attracted to their cousins,
but they always use the excuse.
They're not blood related and they've
well done.
Yeah,
that's not real.
I wouldn't have sex with a relative.
Just not into it,
but I think people have done it
throughout history.
I think it's kind of sick.
Why you don't see them that often?
I just think it's sick day.
I think incest is a sickening thing and
I'm sorry it's happened to some young
girls or kids or whatever.
I mean it would've been thing.
What if it's a cousin that you really
enjoy?
I think a cousin is too close,
but what of it?
Look what if that cousin is the perfect
person for you?
What if you know it does.
It doesn't make sense,
but you know what the heart wants,
what it wants brody and then one that's
not normal.
And so if you look at the way we treat
[inaudible],
why the fuck would we ever expect
anybody to
be nice to us?
I used to exercise the analogy of um,
of aliens with the younger trainers all
the time.
I'd say,
look,
we're aliens to these animals.
You need to make this animal's
environment as comfortable as possible.
Bearing in mind always we are aliens.
Just,
you know what I mean?
That's part of relating to the animals
which is or thing like that.
You're just like,
wait a second,
like I got to start being nicer because
if an alien comes down,
I don't want that.
I don't want.
It
sounds like it's a stupid thing to say
like it's one of those who's your
target.
Again,
people like automatically go goofy with
it.
But the reality is it's actually,
it's the right analogy because we really
are aliens in the world and we're
obviously supposedly intelligent.
We're obviously intelligent enough to
figure out how to get them.
We're intelligent enough to figure out
how to train them,
put them in tents,
put them in tanks rather.
Have all these people come to see him.
We're obviously intelligent.
Have to film them.
They
can tell there's a lot of shit going on
that they don't do,
but they've got to be like,
God,
you guys are dicks.
Like,
why are you holding onto me?
Like we don't.
Hold on.
We don't.
We don't,
we don't do that.
I think we killed things,
but we don't hold onto them.
I think that's when the frustration
level start boiling for these animals
because when they're first,
when they first arrived here as a green
animal,
if there.
I mean the bottom line is it depends if
they're a good candidate for captivity,
but they learned real fast that,
okay,
that's the hand that feeds me.
Like I wanna I wanna I want to develop
this relationship if you will,
which is an relationship of abiding by
this person's race.
Right?
So and again,
goodwill,
the animals and the other ones that are
just like,
this ain't for me.
They're,
they're,
they're cutting out and there's nothing
you can do.
I mean,
you pull blood from them,
you check that blood.
There's nothing wrong with them.
This animal's not sick.
Why isn't it eating?
And then days later,
why is this animal dead did not want to
be in captivity.
They just starve themselves to death.
I've seen it so many times.
Wow.
The will to live loss.